all right so let's have a look at this
next example which is a bit harder but
it's still within the scope of what you
guys will be expected to do y equals x
plus 2 on x squared minus 1 we're going
to look at the same features that we're
trying to work out before let's begin
with those intercepts and start with the
x intercept so we let y equal 0 and you
can see here if I just do a straight
substitution this highlights what we
were talking about before that if you
have X plus 2 on x squared minus 1
equals 0
it doesn't matter what value of x you
put into the denominator you will never
get something on the right-hand side
which is 0 right what you want is for
this numerator to equal 0 you want X
plus 2 to equal 0 so X must be negative
2 so this guy here is our x intercept
and so we want into a y-intercept so I'm
going to do exactly the same thing but
in Reverse I'll let X equal 0 and when I
did this substitution you can see up
here in the top right you've got this X
term which becomes nothing this X term
also becomes nothing so you just get
left with 2 on negative 1 which is
negative 2 so there's our y-intercept
intercepts check now let's think about
our asymptotes so I'm going to look for
vertical asymptotes and then I'm gonna
look for horizontal ones so vertical
let's have a think about this remember
going back to what we were saying before
these come from domain discontinuities
so places where the function explodes
and stops working for us that means
where the denominator is equal to zero
now if you have a look at our function
here here it is the denominator there is
x squared minus one if that denominator
were equal to zero we know this is what
will give us a discontinuity so we can
go ahead and we can solve this equation
you can see I can factorize on the left
hand side there because I've got
difference of squares move that equal
sign so it's all in line and this gives
us not one but actually two different
solutions which means there are two
vertical asymptotes so x equals negative
1
or x equals one now in the case of 1
over X or this previous example here
what was that 2x minus 1 on X plus 2 we
noticed there was just one vertical
asymptote but if you make your
denominator if you make that polynomial
more complicated if it's a cubic or if
it's a quarter or anything like that you
can introduce as many vertical
asymptotes as you like so this time
we've gotten 2 then lastly let's work
out our horizontal asymptotes now like I
mentioned before there's lots of ways to
work this out but probably the simplest
way is just to throw in some very large
positive values and some very large
negative values so if I say x equals a
thousand what would that mean if I go to
this function here you can see I'm gonna
get y equals a thousand plus two which
is a thousand and two divided by the
thousands gonna get squared so it's
going to be a million minus once that's
999,999 now have a look at this
evaluation here you can see that this is
going to have such an enormous
denominator that even though the
numerator is also large the denominator
is always going to be bigger and that's
because you can see it's the denominator
has an x squared term inner so no matter
how big the numerator gets I can put in
x equals a million or x equals a billion
the denominator will always get bigger
faster so that means that you're always
going to get this enormous denominator
here which means that Y is approaching
zero but importantly you might notice
that you've got a positive value here on
the numerator in the denominator so
therefore Y is approaching zero but it's
approaching it from above that's
crucially important as you approach X is
positive infinity Y is going to get
closer and closer to zero but it will do
it from positive values now the reason
why that's worth highlighting is if you
try out the other side x equals negative
a thousand and go ahead and pop back on
you when you evaluate this let's go back
up you can see it's negative thousand
plus two so that's
negative 998 and then on the denominator
you've got x squared minus 1 which is
negative 1000 all squared well that just
like before is actually 999,999 because
x squared is an even function so if you
put in a positive or a negative of the
same size you get the same values so the
important thing is again you've got an
enormous denominator this thing is
becoming very very close to zero but
it's 0 from the negative side you can
see that from that numerator there write
a negative divided by a positive
irrespective of their size and negative
divided by a positive will be negative
so you're going to get very small
negative values okay so what does this
tell us together you're you're
approaching 0 on the right hand side
you're approaching it on the left hand
side so your horizontal asymptote from
all of this information here will be y
equals 0 okay now what you can see here
let's assemble all the information
you've got x intercept of negative 2 y
intercept of negative 2 two vertical
asymptotes x equals negative 1 and x
equals 1 and then you've got a
horizontal asymptote y equals 0 this is
a really good opportunity to remind you
as you're doing your working please tell
us what you're working at don't just you
know have a mess of equations here and
think oh I'm gonna let X equal 0 and
that'll mean something else I know
that's what your brain is doing but I
have to know what that actually gives me
because otherwise like x equals negative
2 on the previous question
that wasn't an intercept that was an
asymptote these equations here can stand
for radically different things it's the
words it's the language you use around
that working that actually decides what
does it actually refer to okay all right
so I have all my main pieces here what
I'm gonna do is I think actually need a
bit more space so I'm going to move this
guy who composes homework later on let's
move this out the way okay and now what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna draw my I'm
going to draw my Cartesian plane and I
need enough room to do that so let's
make this all a little bit smaller pop
it up there
and then let's draw ourselves an X and a
y-axis that it's an appropriate size
okay so hey that's enough space go ahead
vertical line horizontal line there we
go and let's put some some tails on
these guys okay now I've got a lot of
information already about this graph you
can see I worked out my X and my Y
intercepts they are going to be at let's
put in negative 1 negative 2 there's my
negative 2 intercept for the x-axis and
then I've also got a negative 2x is for
the intercept for the y-axis so I'm
gonna go ahead and put that there so my
intercepts check I'm gonna move this
because it's a bit harder to read it's
beautiful right there then I'm also
going to get my asymptotes now you might
recall this is the one where I worked
out there were two of them X is negative
1 and X is positive 1 so I'm going to go
ahead and Mark in that's that's actually
already right there that's x equals
negative 1 there so I'm just going to
draw my vertical asymptotes clean
through it like so that's x equals
negative 1 then I need the other one on
the opposite side so we're put in a
positive 1 there drawing down once again
and that's x equals 1 now lastly and
this is gonna be really important here
because you'll start to realize why we
did some of the theory earlier on I'm
now gonna be my horizontal asymptotes
and I wonder if you notice something
unusual I'm gonna start over here on the
right hand side there's my X sorry my y
equals 0 horizontal asymptote that I
worked out just up here okay so it's
sitting on the x-axis like so I'm just
drawing my lines across and then as you
draw all the way across you might
realize you hit this guy this is the
intercept right now we already worked
out and intercept X instead before it's
like the first thing that we calculated
but we also found that y equals 0 was a
horizontal asymptote so this is an
example of a graph that passes directly
through its horizontal asymptotes the
horizontal asymptotes only tells you
about the extreme values the very far
left and the very far right in the
middle of the graph
a horizontal asymptote doesn't tell you
anything so you can intersect right
through it just like we were seeing
before